Let's solve some more sample tasks
with graphics of rational functions.
Let's say I have y = 2x / (x + 1).
First, let's find the horizontal ones
asymptotes, if any.
As I said before, we only need to see which one
is the highest degree in numerator and denominator.
Well, we have only 2x here
and x here -
both are of first grade.
So when x goes to infinity,
or when taking extremely high values,
these two members will dominate.
It will not matter much.
Then y will be approximately equal
at 2x / x or just at 2.
In fact, the same is true if x
Tend to minus infinity.
That is, when x becomes extremely large or small,
this will turn to 2.
This article will not matter much.
Let's draw this horizontal asymptote.
So this is y = 2.
Let's make the chart.
Here's her horizontal asymptote.
y = 2, let me write this.
Horizontal asymptote.
Here's what's approaching our chart, but never reaching,
when we get more and more positive
or increasingly negative values ​​of x.
Now, do we have vertical asymptotes?
Yes of course.
When x = -1, the function
is undefined.
That is, we say y is undetermined when x = -1.
This is certainly true, because when x = -1,
the denominator becomes 0.
We do not know what is 1, divided by 0.
This is an undefined value.
And this is a vertical asymptote,
because (x + 1) is not abbreviated
with nothing else.
Let me give you a quick example.
Let's say I have the equation y is equal
of (x + 1) on (x + 1).
Here you might say that when
x = -1, my chart is undefined.
And it will be true because if we put -1 here,
below we will have 0.
In fact, we will get 0 above.
We will have 0 on 0.
This is indefinite.
But as we can see, if we assume that x is not
equal to -1 or that these members are not 0,
we can divide the numerator and the denominator into (x + 1).
Or we can say that
this on it (that is, on itself)
will be equal to 1.
You can say that this will be equal to 1 when
x is not equal to -1 or when these members are not 0.
When x = -1, we will have 0 on 0,
which we do not know what it is.
So in this situation we would not
had a vertical asymptote.
Here, this graph has no vertical asymptotis.
Actually, maybe you're wondering
how would the chart look like?
I will draw it.
If I had to draw the chart here,
y would be equal to 1 for all values,
except for x = -1.
Here is the graph in this situation - y = 1 anywhere,
It is then indefinite.
So here we have to have a hole.
Here we draw a small concave circle,
because we do not know what y will be,
when x = -1.
It would look like something like that.
As horizontal rights.
We have no vertical asymptote.
This is because this and this member are being cut short,
when they are not equal to 0
or when x is not -1.
Let me make it clear that when looking for vertical asymptotes,
we need to make sure this expression here
is not abridged by anything from the numerator.
And in this case it is not abridged.
And in this case it is shortened, so
we have no vertical asymptote.
In this case, because it is not abridged,
we have a vertical asymptote.
x = -1 is a vertical asymptote
for this chart.
So x = -1; let me draw
the vertical asymmetry - it will look like this.
And now, to see what the chart is doing,
we can try with several values.
What happens when x = 0?
When x = 0, we have 2 at 0, which is 0,
on (0 + 1).
Which is 0 on 1, which is 0.
The point (0; 0) is on our curve.
What happens when x = 1?
We have 2 by 1, which is 2 on (1 + 1).
Or 2 on 2, which is 1.
That is, (1; 1) is also on our graph.
That's on our schedule.
We can continue to score points,
but we know that the curve will look like something like that.
It seems that it tends to minus infinity,
when approaching the vertical asymmetry on the right.
So in this direction it tends to minus infinity.
And then our horizontal asymptotic approach
from the negative direction.
It will look like this.
And now, let's do this in a darker color,
for example in red.
What happens when x = -2?
We have -2 at 2, which is -4.
We have -4
on (-2 + 1) or on -1,
which is just 4.
That is, we have (-2; 4).
(-2; 4).
(-2; 4) is on the graph.
Let's make one more point.
Let's try -3.
We'll get the -3 point
2 on -3 is -6, on (-3 + 1),
which is -2.
-6 on -2 is +3.
We are looking for a point (-3; 3).
1, 2, 3.
Here it is.
The graphics will look like something.
When x tends to minus infinity,
our graph will approach the horizontal asymmetry from above.
When x climbs to -1,
the function will tend towards plus infinity.
Let's make sure once again that this is true
is the graph of our function.
Let's get our graph of function graphs.
We will define y as 2x / (x + 1)
is equal to (we delete all this and we want to plot that) ...
Here. It looks exactly like
our schedule.
And this vertical asymptote - the calculator linked the points,
but we know that our function here is undefined.
The calculator just tried to connect
extremely positive values ​​down.
What the calculator does is yes
create a detailed set of values
and simply link all the points.
He does not know that this is asymptote,
so he tried to join the dots.
But they must not be connected.
I hope this example has been useful to you.